if you were shocked by these images from
under the bridge in del rio texas get
used to it because the border surge is
just getting started panama is warning
up to 60 000 mostly haitian migrants are
heading north that's double the number
that we saw cross into del rio earlier
this month making matters worse the
department of homeland security is
reportedly preparing for a record surge
at the border in october jesse i wonder
why
the slogans come on down that's right
and i heard the panamanian woman say
that we warned joe biden months ago that
caravans were coming and joe didn't
listen does that sound familiar to you
guys it's warning about afghanistan
worrying about inflation
mansion warned them about what his top
dollar number was in july what does he
do all day he sits in a soft chair in
delaware and lets susan rice run the
country
if you think you can turn texas blue you
have a generation to do it that's the
goal but it's going deep red in the
short term poll came out texas hispanics
he's at like 30 percent approval with
texas hispanics only 25 percent of texas
hispanics support what joe biden's doing
on the border right now
remaining mexico policy is such a gift
trump gave this guy and joe's just
spitting on it let them stay in mexico
and apply for asylum there we have so
much leverage over our southern
neighbors what do we do hundreds of
billions of trade each year with mexico
we protect their security monroe
doctrine and how about some vaccine
diplomacy if i was joe biden this is
what i'd do i'd say you're a country
where they have about 130 million people
in mexico
we just gave him a million coveted shots
joe biden just gave him a million i'd
dangle about 20 million more shots over
mexico city i'd say we do this for you
guys all you have to do is stop the
caravans
why doesn't he think of that it's not
yeah much just
why doesn't he think of that
i think if i can think of it shirley joe
can i believe that for sure and it's
interesting there's a meeting uh next
week on the 8th i believe uh blinken
mayorkas and merrick garland are all
heading down to mexico city uh to have a
chat about what's going on and it'll be
interesting to see what the news that
comes out of there that i was reading an
article said you know we we're not sure
if they'll talk about immigration
they're going to be talking about
immigration and what they can do and we
can't just
tell mexico to keep everybody there have
to be incentives to do that and we have
to broker some sort of new deal that is
going to work
right now the biden administration is in
court still over the remaining mexico
policy which actually came out of effect
even during the trump years because of
the covet 19 pandemic because they
didn't want people just freely crossing
or hanging out in mexico frankly uh with
the disease but it'll be interesting to
see what comes out of that meeting chat
a chat's going to solve it meantime you
want to talk about the demonization of
border patrol demonization of border
patrol on horseback with these hideous
lies
what does that do to the enforcement it
certainly discourages anybody from
joining the patrol and it it puts people
back on their heels dan yeah i mean i
remember being in uh in fletc the
federal law enforcement training center
and we had we with border patrol they're
usually the biggest constituency down
there and you know on the weekends when
you're off you just hang out at the pool
and you talk they were just great guys
and women who did it and you think to
yourself like why would you do this
anymore i don't understand like we don't
have a border can we just please i mean
stop the silliness that there's a
southern border what is a border do you
understand the definition of a border
it's a delineation point between two
land masses here's our country here's
yours so if the theory is well you can
kind of walk back and forth however you
want and by the way when you come in
we'll admit you win and we'll give you
benefits as well then why are you even
saying we have a border it's you could
call it a unicountry you could call it a
landmass but the border is not designed
to be a suggestion and again like to the
democrats on this i get tired of this
whole like they just the sergeant
schultz i don't know nothing i don't see
nothing so the highest numbers we had
under president trump of border
encounters about 60 000 i think their
highest ever was a hundred thousand
we've had about 180 to 200 000 a month
under obama the democrats like oh my
gosh like jesse said what the hell
happened gee i don't know we stopped
building the wall we stopped to remain
in mexico and we told everybody to come
here like democrats aren't dumb like you
think they don't know this this is
clearly intentional and we should stop
pretending it isn't it is you know well
it adds and speaking of which the
warning to mayorkas was about 300 to 150
to 400 000 migrants possibly crossing
the border in october that's that's the
double what they're getting
exactly i have a hard time martha
organizing a you know small family
gathering to go to dinner dozen people
is just undoable unfeasible to go out to
a restaurant how is it that these tens
of thousands of people
managing to make their way from all
these countries in such an organized
fashion making it into the united states
i mean because now is the time you know
most of them have been in these
countries for two or three years so
they've decided that now is the time and
they look at what happens they hear what
america says that the borders closed but
they don't they don't need to listen to
that because they see what they see with
their own eyes and that is that their
relatives and people that they know are
getting in and who can blame them for
wanting to come but the fact of the
matter is that joe biden said during the
campaign you know we could in a
heartbeat we could take 2 million
our numbers are too low in terms of who
we're taking in so so the strategy has
been quite clear and that is to allow
people to come but unfortunately for
them we had a drone at the southern
border and we had images that were
captured by that drone that started to
change people's opinions and that is why
and i think jesse brings up a great
point what's happening in texas is
something that the rest of the country
needs to watch very closely there are
three very contested congressional races
down on the border in texas currently
held by democrats when you look at
hispanic voters who are
increasingly wanting to elect a
republican or someone who's going to
take the border seriously you have a
very interesting trend the last election
president trump got more hispanic votes
than the prior elections um and in that
election he got more than than previous
republicans had before so watch these
trends because um this is not something
that is popular with voters that have
been typically democrat voters and
talking about incentives you illegal
immigrants can get more than fifteen
thousand dollars from why wouldn't you
come and covet relief 15 15 grand it's a
better place to live there's more jobs
and you get free money and health care
so why wouldn't you come i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now